bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end comme
vous le savez tous les vendredis nous
revenons sur les moments forts de
l'actualité culture sports et loisirs
alors au cours de cette émission nous
vous donnerons quelques idées de sorties
pour ce week end mais aussi pour la
semaine prochaine puisque nous parlerons
de la comédie rock fantastique
le cadeau avec nos invités lucie était
là et seul tir bonjour mais avant nous
présenter votre spectacle nous allons
d'abord parler cinéma en ce début de
semaine manu payet animateur radio et
télé comédien est maintenant réalisateur
était à l'ugc de saint quentin en
yvelines
il y présentait situation amoureuse
c'est compliqué une comédie romantique
très personnel wilfrid richie et le
diwan
j'ai trouvé ça très drôle très amusant
et je le conseille à tout le monde
très bonne comédie très mal à aller voir
vraiment aller voir d'urgence
très sympa
non pas parce que je veux dire qui est
entré dans mon bureau temps plus tard
que hier vanessa mais c'est lindsay
tanner ça pestait avec ses miches un
million de dollars la plus belle
gonzesse quand on est connu toi et moi
y'a du mois
un mariage pas forcément bien engagé un
amour d'enfance qui resurgit un
trentenaire en plein dilemme le point de
départ du premier film en tant que
réalisateur et scénariste de manu payet
je ne connais pas de films français qui
est déjà évoqué cette fille
cette star du collège ou du lycée la
fille dont tout le monde était jaloux où
tout le monde était amoureux et qui est
resté un peu dans nos têtes à nous voilà
moi je me suis encore deux sont
évidemment de son prénom et son nom est
à chaque fois que pose la question à un
copain il me sort que roberti quand je
me suis rendu compte que ça concernait
un peu plus de gens que que moi voilà j
ok il faut qu'on en fasse un film il
faut qu'on en fasse une comédie
romantique dont koledy romantique très
apprécié du public de l'ugc skywest et
lauréate du dernier grand prix du
festival du film de comédie de l'alpe
d'huez aux côtés de manu payet pour
présenter le film ce soir là son
coréalisateur rodolphe lauga elle sa
future épouse à l'écran la comédienne
anaïs demoustier et un ami pour le moins
envahissant dans ce film jean françois
carré j'aime beaucoup ce film parce
qu'il me ressemble beaucoup
parce qu'il me fait encore rire alors
que j'ai vu vous imaginez un grand
nombre de fois mais qu' on n'y a mis
plein de réplique qu'on adore avec
romain et plein d'acteurs
qui nous qui nous font rire et qui nous
émeuvent à l'intérieur il ya pas de
signe tu avec juliet cl ta meuf
cette complémentaire infinie refaire la
mousse la joie techwin absolument que tu
as des bêtes
l'afutt de juliette situation amoureuse
c'est compliqué à la fiche le 19 mars
une sortie délicate alors que sont
annoncées plusieurs comédies et que
reste toujours à la fiche les inconnus
ou encore dany boon on le comédien sam
karmann installés dans le département le
choix est en tout cas déjà fait il ya de
la vanne c'est drôle c'est à tomber par
terre de drôlerie mais en plus il ya du
curé c'est bien joué moi je sais que les
places sont chères tous les mercredis 20
ya plusieurs films français mais si la
comédie mais en ce moment donc
mais ouais il n'y a pas que des bonnes
salles assez une bonne alors c'est une
comédie musical mélangeant le rock le
fantastique c'est aussi une réflexion
sur des questions existentielles
le spectacle s'appelle le cadeau il sera
donc présenté jeudi prochain à 19h30 à
la salle jeanne à la salle jacques-brel
de montigny le bretonneux par
l'association art magique alors lu 6
dallas vous êtes la metteur en scène de
ce spectacle vous est également
professeur de danse au sein de votre
association art magique vous êtes venu
accompagné de soheil tir alors vous vous
êtes le scénariste de ce spectacle le
cadeau est ce que vous pouvez commencer
par nous expliquer en place qui
racontait dans ce spectacle d'accord
alors le cadeau c'est l'histoire de deux
personnages qui sont enfermés dans une
boîte dans l'espace quelque part entre
deux dimensions qui tourne autour de la
terre
ils ne savent pas pourquoi ils sont là
autour de cela l'un des deux a un dont
le passeur il a le don d'intervenir sur
les êtres humains à partir de là il se
pose beaucoup de questions
existentielles et à travers toute la
pièce
on va découvrir pourquoi ils sont dans
cette boîte alors comment ça vous est
venue cette idée de cette idée de boîte
c'est par rapport à un regard
si on nous êtres humains que l'on peut
avoir mais avec un décalage avec un
décalage peut plus spirituelle et voilà
d'accord vous êtes assis une musicien au
sein de l'association art magique alors
au niveau de la composition musicale du
spectacle donc c'est une comédie
musicale un peu de rock et surtout de me
sentir un petit peu plus d'accord alors
ça c'est quand même la plus grosse
partie du travail à faire c'est la
composition musicale puisque c'est une
comédie musicale tournée but est de
mettre le scénario en musique au maximum
donc ça prend un certain temps à
construire les morceaux et à poser des
paroles en français parce que le
français n'est pas une langue très très
évidente pour la faire chanter
vous allez tous créés alors les paroles
c'est vous qui la plupart des trois
quarts de travail j'ai travaillé en
collaboration avec hélène jenny qui sera
donc un des personnage principal de la
pièce et michel aussi qui a participé au
texte
sur cette pièce là la tendance est
plutôt rock parce que c'est une de mes
sources
une de mes principales influences et que
ça se passe bien au thème aussi c'est
une comédie qui va assez vite et se
prête au thème
il ya aussi pas mal de balade musicale
mais toujours sur un fond manque
d'accord alors lui sita l'a donc vous
avez mis en scène ce spectacle
si donc une comédie musicale à la fois
parlé chanté comment vous avez mis en
place alors comment est-ce que j'ai mise
en place c'est comme je mets en place
les comédies musicales à partir d'une
histoire enfin il ya la place paix tout
à fait technique d'abord tout à fait
méthodique que la commande hier la
méthode qui est la mienne de mise en
place d'une comédie musicale donc je
veux pas entrer dans des détails de
méthode mais à partir de l'histoire
écrit soheil j'essaye de comment dire de
diviser cette histoire en différents
tableaux voir et après c'est vraiment
une question d'imagination de créativité
et de me dire comment est ce que je
pourrais rendre ce moment fantastique
parce que sont sa comédie est
fantastique et comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait amener à faire rêver les gens
là dessus donc voilà lui il a déjà des
idées relativement précises soit elle
avait déjà des idées relativement
précise de ce qu'ils voulaient voir dans
son spectacle et donc moi j'arrive je
fais des propositions pour lier tout ça
pour qui et que le fil conducteur soit
toujours là et qui est un certain rythme
aussi dans le spectacle qu'ils ne soient
pas monocorde qu'il y est voilà qui les
différentes ambiances et on essaye de
trouver le comment dire de bons
enchaînements
et puis après il ya la mise en scène
ne travaille vraiment scénique avec les
intervenants de travail scénique avec
ceux qui doivent jouer la comédie parce
que ce comédie musicale il comédie la
musique et la comédie
donc voilà il ya un travail vraiment
scénique à travailler avec des personnes
qui ne sont pas forcément connaît bien
il ya voilà je crois qu'il ya un
comédien
si je ne m'abuse vous abordez il me
semble des sujets importants comme le
racisme la confiance oui tout à fait
alors on a d'une part pour le côté
fantastique un questionnement sur
l'existence notre but
dans cet univers notre relation à
l'univers avec les différentes croyances
que sont les populations
et puis du côté terrestre donc plus
prosaïquement parlant on aborde des
sujets on les traite on ne les développe
pas on les traite mais aborde des sujets
comme le racisme l'homophobie la
confiance en soi et surtout le lien des
deux c'est la loi de l'attraction qui
qui est qui est là partout présente dans
ce que l'on fait et ce que l'on génère
et les conséquences que ça c'est quand
même des sujets assez important c'est
quand même destinée à tous les publics
ce spectacle c'est accessible à tous en
skiff 1 si je peux répondre je pense que
quand il parle de lois de l'attraction
pour moi ça concerne tout le monde est
justement de l'idée c'est de mettre en
scène de manière à ce que ce soit
compréhensible pour tout le monde sans
partir dans des explications trop
soutenu trop trop techniques trop
incompréhensible de ce que peuvent de ce
que peut être cette loi de l'attraction
que je pense que tout le monde est
concerné par la loi de la gravité par la
loi de l'attraction voilà donc ces
amateurs et professionnels confondus
ses parents sont des membres de votre
association art magique je suppose sont
pas tous à tous a tout fait nous avons
des gens qui sont
au sein des adhérents de l'association
il ya des professeurs qui sont de
l'association et nous avons aussi appelé
des gens à l'extérieur
vous êtes très nombreux dans
l'association vous êtes environ 300
adhérents
c'est bien cela même si c'est vous qui
avez créé en 2002 qu'est ce que vous
proposez aujourd'hui au sein de votre
association art magique
il ya des chemins effectivement de
parcouru depuis 2002 à l'époque il y
avait un cours de danse à 10 personnes
qui étaient donnés par moi-même et voilà
le chemin faisant plusieurs cours de
danse se sont développées dans le hip
hop et la salsa pour commencer ensuite
plus tard la musique a rejoint
l'association donc aujourd'hui il ya des
cours de zumba de hip hop de salsa de
multidanse n'ont pas d'âme en mélange
plusieurs types via danse la musique la
musique et en production de spectacles
globalement dance music la production de
spectacles et puis animation six
animations d'événements et il existe en
groupes de musique au sein d' art
magique qui s'appelle alpha project qui
voilà qui se produit à la demande très
bien coaching aussi les piliers
il ya du théâtre qui doit arriver aussi
le théâtre arrive comme ça
les théâtres arrive effectivement la
prochaine rentrée
très bien alors je le rappelle votre
spectacle le cadeau sera présenté jeudi
prochain le 21 mars à montigny le
bretonneux
il est encore temps de réserver merci à
vous est venu sur notre plateau merci à
bien des mots dessus
et bien alors on reste à présent dans le
monde du spectacle pour les 30 ans de
hip hop à saint quentin en yvelines le
prisme programme en mars trois
représentations de danse il a donné
carte blanche à kader attou l'une des
figures marquantes du hip hop
nicolas gervais l'a rencontré pour que
notre sa sélection il est présente
notamment deux spectacles le premier
appelé rage d'anthony egéa présenté ce
vendredi 22 14 mars et le deuxième c'est
le spectacle d'anne nguyen appelé
promenade obligatoires et sera jouée ce
dimanche 16 mars à 16 heures voilà de
bonnes idées de sorties pour ce week end
voici un extrait de leur encontre
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que la danse
hip hop
le hip hop à une nation mondiale c'est à
dire qu à caracas à calcutta en afrique
ou ailleurs vous trouverez ces danseurs
hip hop ça c'est certain
on se nourrit forcément de là où on
vient en fait c'est notre hip hop en
france et nori de la danse contemporaine
par exemple et d'autres choses
en afrique elle s'épanouit de la danse
contemporaine elle s'est nourrie
forcément d'autres choses et de leur
histoire à ses danseurs la cua et donc
ça a donné quelque chose assez
extraordinaire en tout cas et dans la
façon de vivre et dans la façon de
danser anthony en tout cas avec ses
danseurs il est il est parti explorer
toute cette rage qu'incarne de craintes
les versions afrique et ça c'est un
cocktail assez étonnant
on parle de karting on parle de femmes
on parle d'homme aussi contrairement à
la quasi d'anthony et de fer et de
moi-même yak des hommes and as cannes en
tout cas la féminité et
danse au féminin au hip hop et dans
promenade obligatoire ne serait-ce que
la proposition
elle même est intéressante c'est une
chorégraphie en discontinu comme ça de
part et d'autre c'est à dire de de cour
à jardin sans qu'il y ait un moment
donné les sans arrêt c'est à dire que
les danseurs traversent le plateau
pendant une heure sur une chorégraphie
très élaboré
il ya quelque chose de très hypnotique
en fait dans ce travail là et c'est vrai
que tout les aspects esthétiques entre
autres le popping le smurf le boogaloo
aussi des danses debout hip hop
il est largement représentée quoi et
donc du coup ça fait ça fait pour moi
une sorte de de contrepoids avec la
proposition de la nuit et celle de manon
et une info d'importance encore avant de
nous quitter sachez que pour une place
achetée pour wedge c'est une place
offerte pour promenades obligatoires le
cese alors de spectacles pour le prix
dans on ne s'en prive pas il ya quelques
jours à montigny le bretonneux
l'auteur de au revoir là haut pierre
lemaître prix goncourt 2013 est venu à
la rencontre de ses lecteurs
l'occasion pour lui d'échanger sur sa
façon de travailler
un reportage de sabrina sikinis et
d'élodie moines les venues leur raconter
une histoire l'histoire du livre qui lui
a permis d'atteindre la consécration
loin des projecteurs hier lemaitre est
revenu sur les origines de revoir la aux
primés l'année dernière par l'académie
goncourt
l'occasion pour l'écrivain passionné par
la première guerre mondiale de
rencontrer des lecteurs dont il se sent
parfois éloignés vous savez le travail
d'un romancier c'est un travail assez
solitaire et le moment de la parution
d'un livre c'est la seule occasion de
l'année que vous avez de de rencontrer
les gens au fond pour qu'ils vous
écrivez lors de cette rencontre pierre
lemaître a séduit son public
en alliant convient danse et traits
d'humour toujours j'ai écrit des romans
il se passe des trucs totalement
invraisemblable
globalement ça marche
et moi ce qui m'importe c'est l'émotion
pour moi mon boulot mon train mon
travail mon job en racontant des
histoires c'est provoquer des émotions
je suis ni la gym dans la parole de dieu
merci nous poser une question c'est une
opération intéressante pour la librairie
qui a misé sur la notoriété du romancier
pour attirer les lecteurs
pierre lemaître avait écrit des polars
avant de décrire son prix goncourt et ça
faisait longtemps que j'avais envie de
le voir et de faire une rencontre avec
lui je pense que c'est ce et conviviales
amicales d'avoir une relation comme ça
avec un auteur je trouve ça formidable
je trouve ça déjà c'est bien d'avoir à
admettre un visage à à un nom coiffant
sur un bouquin donc dans ses sermons
présent d'air en plus c'est quelqu'un de
très très agréable un qui sait
communiquer des émotions
ça me fait mieux comprendre encore le
livre et ça me donne envie de lire tout
ce qu'il écrit on lit le livre un petit
peu comme un policier on se demande
jusqu'où il va aller et en plus c'est
très très bien écrit c'est tellement
agréable de l'écriture cette adhésion du
public a poussé pierre lemaître a adapté
son oeuvre en bande dessinée
une nouvelle aventure qui leur conduira
peut-être du côté de saint quentin en
yvelines
tous les ans le réseau des médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines organise
des rencontres lectures auprès de
collégiens et de lycéens
cette année l'auteure isabelle
pandazopoulos présente son roman la
décision il raconte l'histoire d'un déni
gros chef de grossesse chez une
adolescente de 17 ans aurélia debussy et
jonathan vie de maintenant c'est au cdi
du lycée de la plaine de neauphle
attrape que se sont rencontré des élèves
de seconde et l'auteure isabelle
pandazopoulos son roman intitulé la
décision a été choisi par une vingtaine
d'élèves pour participer au défi lecture
proposée par les enseignants les élèves
et bien ont tout de suite été accroché
par le thème par le fait qu'une lycéenne
elle couche dans les toilettes du lycée
je pense que le thème le cadre
les a interpellés tout de suite et c'est
l'un des livres qui a eu le plus de
succès un succès couronné par une
rencontre avec l'auteur
une occasion d'échanger notamment sur la
méthode d'écriture le rôle des
personnages et le sujet de fond le déni
de grossesse chez une adolescente un
sujet rarement abordé dans la
littérature jeunesse
c'est absolument pas intérêt c'est un
roman donc je me suis documenté
effectivement pour être plus juste des
sentiments du personnage principal et de
la réalité que je décrivais mais tout
est inventé c'est un bout en tous les
cas c'est extrêmement caricaturée dans
les dans la presse plus que c'est on en
parle des dénis de grossesse quand elles
des infanticides haut quand il ya des
procès par contre la logique et dans ce
dans quoi le personnage les femmes sont
quand elles vivent ça c'est absolument
pas pris en compte ou raconter où on
n'est que dans le spectaculaire
l'idée c'était de d'essayer de
comprendre parce que c'est
extrêmement mystérieux on pense que ça
arrive à personne et que mais en fait
c'est quelque chose qui qui qui l'a qui
est autour de nous mais personne n'en
parle
alors ça m'a intéressé quand j'ai vu le
juge me suis dit j'ai envie d'en savoir
plus moi j'ai pas de point de vue sur ce
que le lecteur de retenir justement
l'idée c'était plutôt de le faire
réfléchir et d'être émue par le parcours
de cette jeune fille et du coup
d'essayer de d'adopter un point de vue
critique plutôt que d'être dans des
pensées stéréotypé qu'on croque tout
seul c'est pas facile n'a pu savoir ce
qu'elle ressentait sur le livre et tout
ça et comment elle l'a écrit dans
quelles conditions à quoi la pensée
quand elle l'a écrit s'enrichissant de
savoir tamoul a fait tous les ans des
rencontres lectures sont organisées par
le réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines
isabelle pandazopoulos rencontrera
collégiens et lycéens du territoire
jusqu'au 21 mars
c'est une belle initiative qui dure
depuis trois ans déjà au collège
sainte-thérèse du mesnil-saint-denis on
a créé une classe appelé quatrième à
projets qui accueille des adolescents en
difficulté scolaire
17 élèves bénéficient alors d'un
accompagnement personnalisé toute
l'année ils travaillent ensemble autour
d'un projet théâtral dans l'émission
culturelle kiosque aurélia de bissy a
reçu la professeure de français ainsi
qu'une élève
voici un extrait de leur rencontre cette
classe à projet théâtral regroupe
dix-sept élèves qui étaient en
difficulté scolaire pour des raisons de
rythm is it est trop importante et il
n'arrive pas à suivre ou pour des raison
de lacunes cognitives qu'il fallait leur
redonner et ses enfants sont rentrés
dans cette classe sur lettre de
motivation c'est à dire qu'on a forcé
personne ce sont les élèves qui écrivent
une lettre pour postuler à cette classe
le but de cette classe est bien
évidemment et toute l'équipe et
et complètement comment dire en
interdisciplinarité transit scolarité
c'est de leur redonner confiance en
leurs justement redonnant des bases les
lacunes et les bases fondamentales des
savoirs mais aussi redonner confiance à
travers un projet ambitieux qu est un
projet de création et qui est un projet
théâtral donc en fait l'oeuvre théâtrale
est au centre du projet et ensuite
toutes les disciplines vont être fédérer
au tour de bouygues de ce projet alors
le projet littéraire peut-être d'abord
première question à toi lise qu'est ce
qui t'a justement ton professeur disait
tu as écrit une lettre de motivation tu
as même passé un entretien avec le chef
d'établissement pour intégrer cette
classe qu'est ce qui t'a motivé pourquoi
tu voulais vous voulez aller dans la
classe quatrième à projets bah je
voulais y aller parce que le théâtre
m'intéressait beaucoup qui me vient
enfin en dehors et aussi pour pouvoir
par exemple ne gérer mes émotions ou
plus pouvoir m'améliorer dans des
matières comme par exemple français ma
porte est justement de la chambre de la
confiance en soi ça m'a permis qu'ils
sont vraiment plus forte aujourd'hui
près la forte est ce que tu as envie de
presque à terme l'idée c'est de secte ur
intègre ou une troisième général ou une
troisième avec un projet professionnel
est ce que aujourd'hui c'est a déjà des
idées de ce que tu veux faire
oui c'est déjà quelques peut-être aidé
lesquels bas par exemple passer des gens
troisième général et puis peut-être
faire souffleur de verre ou
travailler dans le plexi pour la
cinquième année la course du soleil
partaient des yvelines et de
mantes-la-jolie et en marge de la
première édition de cette étape 2014 du
paris nice tous les passionnés de vélo
s'étaient donné rendez-vous un reportage
d' anthony rech et dont les moines la
course du soleil est le premier grand
rendez-vous de la saison cycliste
alors quand elle part des yvelines les
spectateurs ne loue pas l'occasion de
découvrir le peloton aux arts départ et
nice les coureurs voir un petit peu
l'envers du décor c'est impressionnant
non
surtout avec les voitures et aux donc
sans preuve cela le passage d'une grande
course permet souvent de découvrir le
vélo sous toutes ses formes
mais le cyclisme c'est surtout un sport
chargé de braquet historique avec un
tour de france qui a fêté ses 100 ans en
les épopées des copies anti les autres
thévenet ont marqué les passionnés ou
plutôt les cadres sur lesquels ils
réalisaient leurs exploits les systèmes
bus vélo a pas trop changé par rapport à
aujourd'hui des cadres en carbone
déroulera les faire on ne roule plus
avec des boyaux on roule avec des pneus
qui est plus facile et plus facile pour
la réparation
si les yvelines semble devenir la terre
promise du cyclisme avec le passage
régulier du tour de france ce cinquième
départ du paris nice et la naissance du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le monde de la a encore quelques
kilomètres à parcourir
le cyclisme est un sport qui manque de
reconnaissance qui n'est mis au devant
de la scène que
chaque année grâce au merveilleux
panorama quel tour de france on voit que
paris nice ça amène beaucoup de monde
c'est c'est un événement vraiment majeur
nous effectivement notre objectif c'est
de faire venir les gens à la pratique du
cyclisme
que ce soit le cyclisme promenade du
cyclisme compétition tout est ouvert
ah oui pour la petite histoire l'espoir
français nacer bouhanni s'est imposé au
sprint après 162 km et a pris par la
même occasion le premier maillot jaune
de leader
allez on termine cette édition avec
votre agenda du week end
tout d'abord une date qui va ravir les
fans de rollers ce dimanche 16 mars une
roller party est organisée ce sera au
gymnase intercommunal à la verrière
dominic st denis 2 14 heures à 18 heures
ce dimanche 16 mars toujours le cercle
nautique de versailles organise les
traditionnelles régates en aviron
rendez vous sur le grand canal du
château de versailles
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous en
direct avec l'actualité dans le 7-8
l'aktu d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end sur tv fils